AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Hey Swedish man here do you want some "skratta"?
come then [wierd "skratt"]
welcome to "You Laugh You Lose"
YouTube's favorite show!!
yes yes - ah, we don't do the clapping on this one. That's...
[depression.mp4]
let's see how the other video did...
de-de-de-de-de-de-de-de-de
they're all demonetized!
oh, another company claimed the whole video because of a two-second clip
aw, that's great !!1!
that's fine because I especially -
I don't like earning money,
but I especially like when my money goes to someone else
t h a t ' s   h o w   I   l i k e   it
And in that honor, and in that fashion
we are going to have
OUR video - that's right - it's OUR video now
C Y K A   B L Y A T
[Soviet national anthem ;)]
edition.
that's right!
in honor of this new YouTube
your video is my YouTube, my revenue is your revenue
please do enjoy - and have a good time
why earn money, when other people can have that money?!
YES! - more people should have more money !
that's right - people who work for money
should not have money
what are you stOUpid? it's OUR money
shall we start the video or should I just keep ranting about communism [laughing]
- alright
tech-technology 2016 [laughing]
wait, is there more?
oh there is - great
why is he walking like that?
you can tell here immediately that russia
is at least 20 years ahead of america - finally
this is some hidden footage that has not yet been released
we'll see here who can do it faster...
DAMN IT
DAM IT - we were so close
we have not perfected it yet but we are getting there
it's all in the details don't worry
it's just a legality issue
omg - I've seen this one
Translation: (in a joking manner) Are you ok [lying on the ice]?
[is everything fine?]
[huh?]
Yeah.
[fine]
- Are you fishing?
- Yeah, I’m fishing(gibberish)
[yeah, I’m fishing]
- Well then, keep on fishing.
[well then, keep on fishing]
- Are you able to catch any fish at least
[does the fish bite?]
- Uhuh
[yeah]
*indistinct grumbling*
yOU CAN'T JUST SLEEP ON THE SNOW, RUSSIA - please
what are you doing??
it's on a lake! he's sleeping -
a rare russian walrus
you don't see those everyday
what a sight.
what a culture
who said white people don't have culture?
[drunken russian mumbling]
*hits  head*
[ah BLyAt'!]
[ah blYaT']!
[ah BLyAt- ah bly-]
*hits head again*
[ah BLyAt!]
oh! not again! not again!
[ayh BLyAt!]
(and again)
someone hold his head up!
please
[ah BLyAt!]
[aAYye]
what is the average IQ in russia?
it must be at least over... 70
sorry, I don't mean to generalize, of course
we are just having fun here, guys. We are just having a little laugh
come here, my beloved son
what is this..?
who is this dude?is this, like, russian -
good job.
he thinks
give back my bottle-
what is the plan?
wha - what is that cat doing?
oH! oh that's not bad.
no! poor cat!
please
i have only a pan to offer
everyone have an axe..?
she just... brought an axe?
yeah, everyone has an axe. right?
right?
of course.
oh no.
okay... ehh timber?
OH NO
I don't know if I can laugh or not cuz I don't know if the cat is ok or not
ay aY AY AY!
WOAH
HE'S FINE
the cat is fine.
ok now we can use this clip.
what is his job???
Translation: [little chicks? how cute!]
this is too - this is too innocent [lalalalalallaaa]
[woah, what is that?]
[hmm, I need to go check this out]
[there’s no one here]
can someone translate this?? (yeah)
[let’s go check it out]
[what do we have here?]
[hmmm, looks like someone lives in here]
[ok, I’m crawling farther eeehh]
what is he doing?
[HMMM, where am I?]
[here is a dead-end]
[hmm this is just a casual doghou- WTF, WHO IS- NO!]
[GRANDMA!(and dog's name again(VARYA))]
[GRANDMA!(and dog's name again)]
[hell.mp4]
Translation: [It’s good that they give you these treasure chests]
what is this, a russian minecraft channel?
[BLYYYYYYYAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAT!]
[oh no, my mom's back]
[Mom: I’ll fucking kick your ass, what the fuck, huh?]
[I’ll punish you blyat' what the fuck are you doing]
the kid: mom Mom MOm Wha-?? MOM Oww Oww
[Mom: Turn this bullshit off right now, fucking sick of it already]
[but Mom!!!! OWWW]
yeah
that's - that's cool man
that's cool
that's a really cool building, by the way
BLYAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAT
Translation: [FUCKIN GERMANS, SUKA, are crawling along BLYAT!!!!]
[and here is a tank coming, blyat!]
ah yes! the famous battle
man versus giant... bulldozer... thing.
[come on, blyat', you fucking Germans (meaning Nazi army)]
an important piece of russian history.
[come on destroy that sUKA COME ON! *throws fire on tank* GOOD JOB]
woah!
[caterpillar track fucked up! you fucking explode it!!]
[AAAARGH!!
Pizdez blyat! :D]
oh she - he's on fire! he's on fire!
jump out!!
he doesn't even care!
you're on fire!
this is what happens when you don't have internet, ok?
*Russian SWAT team warms up before raiding the club*
the russian military.
fearless as any
some of the strongest fighters on the planet
this is actually not the army, this is the special forces
I can't - it's so dumb, the whole thing
*Arabian Nights in Russian*
it never ends!
I think this is probably one of my favorite "you laugh you lose"
probably we are not using half of these
but I had a great time at least
most likely this won't be monetized properly, but hey!
at least we had fun, everybody
leave a like if you skratta leave a like if you förlora
and remember to laugh - if you laugh you lose
and if you lose you laugh
and so on so forth
thank you for watching, I am your host
PEEEEEEWWWWWDIEPIE
and this is pewdiepie signing off
SUUUKAAAAAAA
BLYAT!
Jake Hill's Pewdiepie Outro #4:
Pewdiepie
with the
Sick so win
Takin' over
YouTube
tryna get like him
Brofist
to the face
Can he keep up with the pace?
And I'm never gonna switch
Pewds: BUT CAN YOU DO THIIIiiiIIIS?!
how's
it
go-
ing
Bro?
Gotta get it like this
When you wanna hit a flow
Grinding like hope when I pop a top and never stop
Run up in the city
and I never gonna flop
Tell me when to go
I'm like:
whenever
I'm done with this
Pass the mic to Edgar.